now whether sake is behind the podium in
the briefing room or in front of a
camera on msdnc she'll be doing the same
thing lying for a living now here with
reaction fox's contributors joe concha
and douglas murray joe who i think is
the best media personality uh the only
objective one not part of the blue check
media mob on twitter who should have his
own tv show i think here on fox anyway
joe uh i thought that student asking
humpty dumpty the question he nailed it
and humpty had no answer
an 18 year old just schooled cnn's chief
media correspondent sean ironically at
an event to discuss the dangers of
disinformation something mr stelter is
patently an expert on for all the wrong
reasons so let's go through these
students points again all right his name
is christopher phillips in his question
one by one he says traditional media
that's like cnn nbc abc cbs washington
post new york times he said that they
pushed the russia collusion coax right
and that is absolutely correct he said
they pushed the jesse smilet hoax that
is correct he said they smeared justice
kavanaugh as a rapist that is correct he
said that they smeared nicholas salmon
as a white supremacist that is correct
and as you pointed out uh salmon
actually sued cnn for 250 million
dollars the network had to settle
because the evidence on that front was
overwhelming he also said that they
dismissed the hunter biden laptop affair
as pure russian disinformation bingo and
then obviously yes all the mistakes of
the mainstream media and cnn he said in
particular seem to all magically go in
one direction i believe i have heard
that somewhere before so then stelter
answers by saying everything that
phillips broached was quote and it bears
repeating a right-wing narrative about
cnn unquote and he does this with a
straight face i mean he proceeds not to
address any of the points that phillips
made oh by the way here's brian stelter
in 2020 in the hunter bind laptop story
we know
now that this is a classic example of
the right-wing media machine unquote so
this has always been the playbook right
sean with stories damaging the democrats
or the media blame the right-wing media
blame russian information and we wonder
why more and more americans see
journalists now as activists and once
that trust is broken it's very hard to
put humpty dumpty back together sean
it'd be interesting to see if jeff
zucker's uh stenographer humpty gets to
stay with new management coming in
douglas let's get your take on it
yeah i absolutely agree with that and i
mean that that comment from ann
applebaum of the atlantic magazine is
also absolutely typical
of the media landscape you've just
described sean you know ann applebaum
is
was a distinguished historian of russia
and much more than in recent years she
went absolutely bananas about a set of
election results she just couldn't
accept her husband and his political
party were chucked out of power in
poland so she decided that polish
democracy wasn't really democracy the
brexit vote happened she didn't like
that so she decided that that hadn't
really happened fairly and on and on
through donald trump but now now we have
her saying on this panel about
disinformation and you just can't make
it up that that she wouldn't have
covered the hunter biden laptop story
because it's just not that interesting
to me it's not that interesting to ann
applebaum that the son of the
soon to be then president of the united
states so then would be president of the
united states was earning 50 000
a month
in a in a discipline he does not have in
an area he knows nothing about in a
country he barely knows that's not
interesting to her it's not interesting
to ann applebaum that in as we know from
miranda divine's book laptop from hell
that that and as you just mentioned in
your opening monologue that that hunter
biden says to his daughter that the big
man his father takes a percentage of all
of his money that he earns you know is
that not interesting to people and and
and there are consequences from this as
you know sean you know we have years of
people making up stuff about russian
collusion we have dozens and dozens of
intelligence operatives pretending that
the hunter biden laptop story was
russian
disinformation and then the american
people become rightly suspicious of all
of the institutions in this country
ukraine russia all of these things the
democrats have made serious foreign
policy issues almost unmentionable in
washington because they're all domestic
issues which they're fighting they're
pathetic domestic wars over
all right douglas great analysis joe
contras always great analysis from you
thank you both hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else